auf diesen sturzflug hat kaum jemand
gewettet von der ewigen kanzler partei
die sich ihre partner nach belieben
aussuchen kann zu einer formation die
gerade das zittern lernt und die wand im
rücken spürt hinter der es nicht mehr
weitergeht im umfragetief was kann die
union noch reißen jetzt in der phoenix
runde
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst jedem studio ist unsere weiten
feld freie wirtschaftsjournalistin und
autorin eine soeben erschienen porträts
über die scheidende bundeskanzlerin hat
sich von lucke ist
politikwissenschaftler jurist und
redakteur der monatszeitschrift blätter
für deutsche und internationale politik
zugeschaltet ist uns anna klaus
korrespondenten des spiegel im münchner
büro also zuständig für bayern und
ebenfalls einer
ebenfalls autorin einer biografie in
diesem fall über markus söder und und
reizt ist bei uns chefkorrespondent bei
focus online willkommen bei uns frau
weiten feld der untertitel der sendung
heißt ja kann ist die union noch rein da
kann es noch reichen ja ich glaube schon
also man sieht ja dass die union zwar
erschreckt ist und verschreckt und auch
verstört aber
die frage wer am ende die koalition
macht also wer die wahl mehr oder
weniger gewinnt und wer dann die
koalition bildet die ist immer noch
offen und darauf wettet die union und
das fällt sie glaube ich die nächsten
zwei wochen noch am leben war von klaus
da wird ja im moment jeder rettende
strohhalm ergriffen es gibt heute eine
neue umfrage da gibt es einen leichten
aufwärtstrend für armin laschet und die
cdu bei einem umfrageinstitut wo im
moment wohl den letzten tagen und wochen
werde die schlecht abgeschnitten hat ist
die messe noch nicht gelesen
also die union ist in der tat immer ganz
gut so im schlussspurt die man hat auch
gesehen bei der bayerischen landtagswahl
zum beispiel vor drei jahren da sagten
die umfrageinstitute der csu werte um
die 32 prozent voraus am ende sie
angelaufen bei 37 prozent ja das war
immer noch das schlechteste ergebnis in
der geschichte der csu damals eben vor
drei jahren heute werden sie dankbar
wenn sie wenigstens dieses ergebnis in
den bund retten würden danach sieht es
ja auch nicht aus aber dieses quasi fünf
noch mal drauf das ist der union schon
zuzutrauen von lucke totgesagte leben
länger diesen satz lassen sie für armin
laschet aber nicht mehr gelten naja das
ist die frage die wir den totgesagten
definieren und sie haben die spannende
frage gestellt kann die cdu ist noch
reisen oder die union ist noch reißen
man muss ja danach fragen was sie reißen
kann wenn wir uns die leser zu eigen
machen er hat am wahlabend dann gesiegt
wenn er gerade noch gegenüber der spd
knapp als gewinner ins ziel 1 kommt das
ist ja jetzt schon genau das was vor
klaus sagen würde oder gesagt hat das
wäre die verschiebung um 5% vielleicht
noch auf 25 prozent zu kommen dann hätte
er die nase vorn es wäre natürlich aber
trotzdem eine solche historische
niederlage es ändert nichts daran
deswegen müssen wir heute schon
aufpassen wie wir diese wahl
interpretieren der absturz der cdu csu
von einer heute hat noch mal die faz zum
besten gegeben von einem umfragewert vor
einem jahr von 40 prozent bei einem spd
wert von 16 prozent ein abstand von 24
prozent auf eine lage bei der armin
laschet vielleicht noch hoffen kann dass
er die nasenspitze vor schulz ist das
würde ich ihn vielleicht in der
wahrnehmung des abends retten weil in
der tat vor weidenfeld hat es gesagt
weil damit auch zwei koalitionen clara
im raum wären jamaika oder die ampel als
mögliche alternativen vielleicht ja
sogar aber ich glaube es will keiner
eine weitere auflage der großen
koalition aber es ändert nichts daran
dass armin laschet als
der spitzenkandidat für die gesamte
union eine so vernichten dahinter in der
lage ein gefragt egal wie die wahl
ausgeht dass die historisches und ein
letztes es ist ein gesamt versagen eine
selbstzerstörung muss es fast zu
formulieren der gesamten union also was
rieso nie geschafft hätte hat die union
in den letzten zweieinhalb jahren
eigentlich werde im letzten vier monaten
selbst geschafft wie effizient das noch
genau im laufe der sendung bereits
attacke
inhaltliche profilschärfung was kann den
ermittler steht jetzt noch helfen
ein paar sachen als armin laschet ja
probiert also wenn ich noch ein satz zu
diesen umfragen das sagen darf ich wäre
grundsätzlich vorsichtig mit umfragen
wurde auch politik gemacht
die leute wollen das ist ein effekt
kennt man seit jahrzehnten schon von
professor neumann die leute wollen beim
sieger sein und deswegen werden umfragen
falsch eingeschätzt im moment vielleicht
sogar stark überbewertet ich erinner mal
an die landtagswahl in sachsen-anhalt
die falsch vorher gesagt worden ist an
die landtagswahl bei der emmy laschet
beteiligt war in nordrhein westfalen
also ich wäre außerordentlich vorsichtig
in der interpretation
herr luca hat in einem punkt recht was
dann eine niederlage ist das stellt sich
wahrscheinlich nicht mal am wahlabend
heraus sondern erst im laufe der
koalitionsverhandlungen
was die union jetzt noch machen kann hat
sie ja schon angefangen ich glaube schon
dass der alte satz von gerhard schröder
wahlen werden in der mitte gewonnen
auch der grund dafür ist dass die union
vor einer linksverschiebung in
deutschland warnt ich glaube das hat
nicht so viel zu tun mit der roten
socken kampagne von peter hintze aus dem
jahr 1994 der alte cdu-generalsekretär
unter helmut kohl
sondern es ist legitim davor zu warnen
wenn die spd keine angst davor hätte
dann würde sie ja auch anders darauf
reagieren deswegen glaube ich dass das
bürgerliche sollte man noch lange nicht
aufgeben und das bürgerliche verbindet
sich mit cdu csu und fdp
gut die frage wieder der lagerwahlkampf
noch erfolg haben kann wollen wir auch
noch ansprechen
frauenfeld gab es denn einen zeitpunkt
wenn wir jetzt uns darüber einig sind
das doch die
cdu/csu in den letzten monaten erheblich
federn lassen musste wo diese zustimmung
zu ungunsten von laschet oder auch zu
ungunsten der union gekippt ist oder war
das ein
feststellbarer zeitpunkt oder war das
ein schleichender prozess der
lange nicht bemerkt worden ist oder
vielleicht auch lange nicht bemerkt
werden wollte ich glaube es war diese
fehleinschätzung zu denken die union
weil sie in den letzten jahren in den
letzten 16 jahren natürlich
regierungspartei geworden ist und
eigentlich als einzige eigenschaft hatte
wir haben die macht wir sind eine
regierung wir haben die kanzlerin und
die fehleinschätzung war das an alle die
die angela merkel als kanzlerin schätzen
diese eigenschaften auf die partei und
deren spitzenkandidaten übertragen olaf
scholz ist von anfang an durch die
gegend gelaufen und hat gesagt wenn wir
eine wahl haben in der es keinen
amtsbonus gibt für die kanzlerin weil ja
nicht mehr antritt dann geht der
sozusagen auf den vizekanzler über also
dann bin ich derjenige der am merkel
haften von allen merkel haften erscheint
und deshalb werde ich dann eben als
spitzenkandidat und das ist ja in dieser
wahl stärker als in jeder anderen wahl
es geht um die spitzenkandidaten es geht
gar nicht mehr so könnten die parteien
und parteipräferenzen dann werde ich als
spitzenkandidat die nase vorn haben ich
glaube die union hat es total
unterschätzt dass es eben keinen
amtsbonus gibt dass es zwar auch keine
wechselstimmung gibt keine echte aber
dass deshalb die cdu auch nicht mehr als
regierungspartei sozusagen als
geburtsrecht regierungspartei
wahrgenommen wird und das glaube ich
jedenfalls wäre unter einem kandidaten
markus söder nicht anders gewesen als
unter einem kandidaten armin laschet
möglicherweise ist eben laschet auch in
seiner in seiner persönlichkeit so um
merkel haft nicht katholisch rheinländer
als anderen ein ganz anderes idiom dass
man das dann eben auch noch mal als
fremder empfindet aber der amtsbonus
scheint eben mit olaf scholz noch auf
der suche nach dem grund für diesen ja
diesen gewaltigen rückgang und diesen
aderlass der union frau klaus ein
vertrauter von armin laschet herbert
reul der innenminister von nordrhein
westfalen hat gestern oder vorgestern
gesagt wir haben das einfach wir waren
zu selbstsicher wir siegen sowie so
haben wir gedacht
war die union in den beginnenden
wahlkampf vielleicht auch noch zu
selbstgefällig
immerhin schafft sie z bemerkenswert
ehrlich zu sein also dieses statement
von roll ist ja wirklich
sehr offen und ehrlich muss man sagen
aber ich würde mich dem anschließen denn
ja markus söder hat schon anfang des
jahres so im hintergrund mit und
journalisten immer gesagt diese 30 oder
knapp 40 prozent die die union damals
noch hatte das sind merkel wehrte das
hat markus söder damals schon ziemlich
klar gesagt und das hat er damals
natürlich auch in den gremien und vor
abgeordneten als er selber sich beworben
hat als kanzlerkandidat immer wiederholt
und gesagt leute verlasst euch nicht
darauf dass diese 30 40 prozent halten
das sind merkel wehrte und
er hat damals das wählerpotenzial der
union das kern wählerpotenzial
eingeschätzt bei knapp über 20 prozent
und genau da liegen wir ja momentan also
auch deshalb sagt markus söder wenn man
ihn fragt ich habe ihn neulich
gefragt herr söder müssen sie eigentlich
nicht zur zeit täglich in die tischkante
beißen vor frust und da hat er dann zehn
minuten lang geantwortet und gesagt nein
natürlich nicht ehrlicher wäre
wahrscheinlich gewesen er hätte einfach
schnell ja gesagt aber ein fünkchen
wahrheit liegt natürlich stimmt
natürlich dass er sagt er kann sich
jetzt zurücklehnen weil er hat damals
ein angebotener sagt gemacht und das
wäre eben gewesen er hat damals gesagt
die union legt im kern wählerpotenzial
bei knapp über 20 um den rest muss man
kämpfen ich bin der bessere kämpfer
aber die cdu-gremien haben sich ebenso
eine rolle es beschrieben hat auf den
amtsbonus von merkel verlassen offenbar
zu unrecht von lucke wenn wir jetzt
diesen begriff davon den merkel werden
bei 40 mal aufnehmen das heißt also wenn
das jetzt mal übertragen auf die heutige
zeit angela merkel hat gar keine
erbschaft hinterlassen
bei der testamentseröffnung war gar
nichts drin was noch zu verteilen waren
war das auch eine fehleinschätzung zu
glauben das geht so von merkel direkt
auf einen cdu kanzler über so in der
sukzession was ist da was ist da falsch
gelaufen oder wieso hat man das falsch
eingeschätzt warum ist das falsch
gelaufen wir stimmen alle zu da ist ja
genau der gleiche befund ja in der tat
die die annahme zu glauben es wird
übrigens auch herr laschet unweigerlich
gewählt das war die annahme von herrn
schäuble die ihn dazu bewogen hat markus
söder zu verhindern das ist doch ganz
klar der fall gewesen diese annahme war
grundfalsch und die eigentliche rooney
besteht darin die eigentlichen kern hat
ein stück weit auf die schwäche der spd
gelegt es hat doch kein mensch geglaubt
ich jedenfalls bin bereit sofort
einzugestehen keiner hat vor einem jahr
geglaubt dass dieser olaf scholz der
übrigens vor einem jahr september schon
drei monate in amt und würden als
kanzlerkandidat war gesetzt worden war
dass er in der lage sein würde diesen
riesigen abstand zu amortisieren und
jetzt findet folgende stadt deswegen
würdig vorweisen fährt er sehr
widersprechen es gab nicht nur eine
merkel autorität es gab ein transfer auf
söder merkel hat in der tat ihre
autorität und das ist übrigens auch der
frust bei söder der sölder france geht
nicht da hin dass die cdu so schlecht
dasteht der söder france geht dahin dass
er dem es gelungen war die sitzt diese
transfer zu leisten hat ja auch ein jahr
geackert er ist quasi ein jahr akten
träger hinter merkel gewesen hat seine
chance von anfang an gesehen er ist in
der korona krise mit allen raffinessen
da muss man gar nicht drüber reden mit
allen fertigkeiten laschet klein zu
halten ist er in die in die rolle von
merkel als hintermann von merkel gelernt
und ich würde ihnen sehr widersprechen
frau weiten feld wenn man nicht
unterstellt dass markus söder die
gleichen fehler gemacht hätte wie armin
laschet denn wir müssen über dieses
lachen sprechen das lachen hat für mein
verständnis armin laschet zentral diese
wahl gekostet denn söder und ich traue
so dass alle mal zu dass er nicht in
dieser flut situation gelacht hätte da
hätte der macht strategie sogar den mund
stillgehalten dann hätte söder ein
gutteil der merkel autorität auch sich
transferiert diese hat laschet verloren
da gibt es zwei gründe dafür er hat sie
verloren zum 1 obwohl das muss man sich
noch mal bewusst machen er hat ja mit
sachsen anhalt nachdem schon seine basis
es war eine rebellion der parteibasis
gegen und nicht nur der parteibasis
gegen armin laschet es haben
ministerpräsidenten vom schlager asolo
vom schlager hans haben gesagt wir
dürfen diesen mann mit aller sympathie
für dich wir dürfen sich nicht
aufstellen wir müssen markus wieder
bringt dann hat laschet sogar das große
glück noch gehabt er gewinnt völlig
unerwartet
kollege reiz hat gesagt er gewinnt
plötzlich also lasche indirekt aber
haseloff gewinnt im web bevor mit einem
riesigen vorsprung damit schien ja
plötzlich laschet fast gerettet dann
kommt das lachen dann kommt das lachen
mit dem alles wieder reduziert wird was
er in der krise in der korona klinikum
jetzt kann ein drittel der ist ganz weg
gehen dann zu einer punkt die cdu hat
nämlich die rechnung ohne markus söder
gemacht markus söder hat natürlich und
das war gewissermaßen ein das war ja
einfach shakespeares gelingen markus
röder hat seine rache quasi ausgelebt
bis vor drei tagen bis vor drei tagen
bis zum csu-parteitag hat uns die
cdu/csu ein schauspiel der
selbstzerstörung die nun das ist der
große anteil denn auch söder an der an
der zerstörung von laschet hat er hat
ihr ein nicht geschlossen er hat nachdem
er einknicken musste nachdem ihm
schäuble und laschet knallhart gesagt
haben wir machen nicht mal wahlkampf für
dich hat er nach wie vor bis vor zwei
tagen und der blume hat es ja bis zum
letzten tag noch gesagt so da wäre
natürlich klar der bessere kann ich hat
er gegen laschet geschossen und das ist
das summa summarum der grund warum
plötzlich ein olaf scholz der nun
wahrlich kein charismatiker ist der nun
wahrlich nicht eine autorität aus
eigenem recht gewesen ist und er nicht 1
lichtgestalt plötzlich diesen laschet so
über runden konnte er
gleich die fortsetzung für den rest der
sendung stichwortartig angesprochen ich
würde aber gern noch die sachen einzeln
ansprechen und bereits
angela merkel welche rolle spielen bei
dem derzeitigen zustand der union
16 jahre angela merkel
das ist für mich einer der zentralen
wenn ich die zentrale frage es knüpft an
das was frau ausgesagt hat es gab ja
nicht nur so da er der meinung war
dass man einen neuanfang brauchen würde
in der union sondern vor ihm war es noch
friedrich merz ich erinnere mich sehr
gut an dass in der konkurrenz um die
frage wer wird der neue cdu vorsitzende
das in dieser konkurrenz friedrich merz
immer argumentiert hat wir sind
strukturell bei 25 prozent damals waren
es gemessene 38 40 märz hat aber gesagt
wir sind strukturell bei 25 wir sind
total schwach wir sind entkernt einer
der besten kenner innerhalb der union
ist ja der professor andreas röder und
dieses board von dem entkernten zustand
der union das stammt von ihm also
sozusagen wenn sie so wollen aus dem
herzen der union selber und das hat auch
friedrich merz gefühlt und gewusst und
da hat er den hat er abgeleitet den
anspruch in stil und inhalten noch mal
völlig neu anzufangen und damals hat man
sich entschieden hat sich die cdu
entschieden diesen weg nicht zu gehen
sondern einen weg der kontinuität
einzuschlagen mit armin laschet und
deswegen ist der anteil von angela
merkel relativ groß weil nicht nur olaf
scholz will weg von angela merkel
fortsetzen sondern
markus söder hat sich auf angela merkel
berufen und armin laschet hat es auch
das heißt wir erleben im grunde genommen
er ein stück weit eigentlich doch die
absurde situation vergleicht man es mit
anderen ländern wie frankreich oder
amerika oder england
das nicht eine kanzlerschaft endet um
damit etwas völlig neues beginnt sondern
eine kanzlerschaft endet um fortgesetzt
zu werden vielleicht mit stilistischen
mitteln oder wie frau werden fällt so
schön gesagt hat mit einem rheinischen
idiom insofern ist der anteil von frau
merkel 16 jahre die cdu entfernt zu
haben
muss man vielleicht sagen ja ist ihre
schuld und ihre
verantwortung das können sie in jedem
einzelnen politikfeld durchdeklinieren
ich sage nur eins ich fand es sehr mutig
ist
armin laschet gesagt hat bei der
energiepolitik haben wir es völlig
falsch gemacht eigentlich hätten wir
zuerst aus der kohle aussteigen müssen
und dann aus der kernkraft wenn es
wirklich ums klima gegangen wäre und wir
haben es falsch gemacht das war
natürlich angela merkel die ist falsch
gemacht hat war dass armin laschet nicht
hat ist den mut zu sagen wir brauchen
vielleicht eine renaissance der
kernkraft mit neuen technologisch neuen
kernkraftwerken den weg denn im moment
etwa bill gates vorschlägt ich heute
keine auf der die inhalte gleich noch
kommen aber
kontinuität in der union von merkel auf
laschet hat das letztendlich dann olaf
scholz in die hand gespielt weil ja doch
angela merkel auch nicht so waren sie
nicht unähnlich ist genau meine olaf
scholz ist der merkel haftete aller
aller kandidaten oder gibt sich so und
ist deshalb ganz offensichtlich auch
derjenige der diesen amtsbonus erben
kann oder erben will ich würde gerne
noch ein wort zu markus sutter sagen
weil markus söder zwar in der union und
da haben die total recht wie sie das
beschrieben haben der kandidat der
herzen war oder wie auch immer aber
markus söder hätte diese dissonanz nie
auflösen können so zu tun als sei er
merkel
aber das ist eben nich markus söder ist
ein klassischer und der wurde ja auch
deshalb in der cdu/csu so geliebt dafür
dass ein klassischer populist und weil
er so populistisch ist hätte er eben
diesen diesen politikstil den ja ganz
offensichtlich ganz offensichtlich alle
kandidaten jetzt denken das ist
fortsetzungs wert und auch die wähler
ganz offensichtlich der auffassung sind
dass es so sein soll diesen politikstil
hätte markus söder nie durchgehalten und
das glaube ich es eben einfach so ein
punkt man kann jetzt immer mit dem ein
halbes jahr zurück gucken und sagen war
das der entscheidende fehler der union
sich am ende dann doch für armin laschet
entschieden
vielleicht noch nicht nur eigentlich
stand aufnahme ganz bestimmten
bestandsaufnahme des zustand der union
sondern auch die ihr der titel der
sendung heißt er kann sie es noch reisen
von klaus bei armin laschet hat man ja
früher hat er sich sozusagen als
rechtmässigen merkel r betrachtet er hat
sich sehr viel auf seine
integrationsfähigkeit zugute gehalten er
hat ja auch diesen ruf tatsächlich zum
beispiel als ministerpräsident in
nordrhein westfalen aber jetzt arbeitet
er quasi als aktivist gegen
steuererhöhungen und bürokratie ist er
da jetzt auf dem richtigen weg mit
diesem server mit dem wandel auch seiner
seiner performance in der öffentlichkeit
da doch noch erwartungen zu befriedigen
die man in ihm gestellt hat er müsse
auch unter anderem ein wahlkämpfer seien
ja in dem wort wahlkampf steckt das wort
kämpfen und das hat armin laschet doch
eher spät bemerkte als früher muss man
sagen ja also sein auftritt zum beispiel
den ich verfolgt haben am wochenende auf
dem csu-parteitag der war sehr
kämpferisch muss man sagen also da haben
sich einige
csu-abgeordnete die am anfang noch so
zwangs mäßig geklatscht haben oder so
das war so eine richtige jubel-arie die
da gegeben wurde als armin laschet
eingezogen ist da braucht man nicht
jedes applaus konnte auf die goldwaage
legen aber am ende seiner rede hat armin
laschet ernsthaften applaus bekommen von
intelligenten weil er durchaus
inspiriert und kämpferisch gesprochen
hat und da war natürlich auch so einen
kinnhaken gegen die spd dabei in die
richtung ja die spd aber bei jeder
entscheidung hat der bundesrepublik auf
der falschen seite gestanden im
nachhinein hat er gesagt er habe ist
auch die wirtschaftspolitik bezogen also
in dem moment in der messe nürnberg wo
die csu getagt hat kam es anders rüber
ja da hat er
engagement bewiesen aber es kommt
natürlich zu spät und deswegen würde ich
an der stelle auch gerne herrn lucke
widersprechen klar markus söder hat
jetzt nicht dafür gesorgt dass die pure
harmonie herrschte in diesem unions
wahlkampf aber armin laschet hat ihn
eben auch immer platz gelassen er wirkte
ja von sich aus wieder gartenzwerg neben
dem baumstamm markus söder
so da würde ich jetzt markus söder an
der stelle ein bisschen in schutz nehmen
also was hat er denn tun sollen also das
ist berührend von der geschätzten
biografien von markus söder aber doch
ein bisschen viel des goodwill frau
korrespondentin in münchen weil er in
der impertinenz raw klaus in der markus
söder übrigens und geschlossen hinter
ihm sein generalsekretär markus blume
vom tage der ausschaltung seiner eigenen
person die ich ihm gar nicht vorwerfen
dass da nicht ein ungeheures bedürfnis
nach großer enttäuschung vielleicht
sogar rache menschlich ist
da habe ich eine völlig andere ansicht
wurde als kanzler ein stückweit
verhindert absolut aber dann die art
derartig penetrant wir haben doch alle
bilder noch vor augen ich weiß nicht wo
er gefragt wurde wird armin laschet
kanzler minuten lang ist überlegen das
war doch also mit qualität wird
wertschätzung frau genauso wenige tage
her das war nicht unterstützung das war
ein dezidiertes bis vor wenigen tagen an
gehaltenes ziel
deutlich zu machen und das ist eine
hypothek die laschet von anfang an hatte
laschet ist der kandidat zweiter wahl
diese kann die dieses diese position
wohl dass ich sie gleich genau die
bibliothek die frau berbalk hat über die
müssen wir auch reden denn so damit ihre
keinen die mutig sondern das ist ein
geschäftsmodell das ist
schwierig für ein ist ich kenne die
geschichte der bundesrepublik gab es
eine wahl meines wissens in der helmut
kohlen oder 80 gezielt franz josef
strauß den vortritt lassen weil er
wusste er wird sowieso verlieren es gibt
am main ist keine hetze lehrern war ein
gezielter sollte doch stoiber gewinnen
es gab keine wahl bei der dezidiert und
so sichtbar der zweit schlechtes der
zweitbeste zweitbeste kandidat für die
cdu csu und die csu als schwesterpartei
das bis zwei wochen vor dem ziel aus
lebt so die faz geht soweit und die
überlegung ist nicht ganz falsch das
würde auch in dem punkt vollkommen auf
eigene rechnung spielt in dem wissen
darum ich lasse lieber armin laschet
diesmal durchfallen und bin jetzt die
nächsten vier jahre der starke mann aus
münchen das war ein kalkül was man
durchaus in einem falle von einem
machtmenschen wie so dass sich
vorstellen kann nur sage ich es ist in
der tat die völlige fehleinschätzung der
spitze der cdu und insofern ist der vor
wird zuallererst gegen wolfgang schäuble
über volker bouffier zu richten die
tatsächlich dafür gesorgt haben dass der
weit stärkerem an markus söder
verhindert wurde dass danach söder und
das hat glaube ich die cdu spitze auch
nicht für möglichkeiten derartig den
eigenen kandidaten beziehungsweise in
der schwesterpartei die ja dann auch
einer der union sein sollte derartig vor
sich hintreiben würde das war das
bereits ein kollege von der faz
besser sie haben das gerade als ich
gekommen jeder der markus oder kennen
sind und schäuble kennt ihn ja besonders
gut hätte das kommen sehen wo sehen sie
müssen das werde ich anregen lässt sich
nicht erpressen zu einem
kanzlerkandidaten der schwesterpartei
wenn man die wahl hat und ich meine man
muss auch sehen in welcher situation war
denn die cdu die hat sich einen
zweijährigen kampf geleistet um die
frage wer vorsitzender nach angela
merkel oder vorsitzende nach angela
merkel werden kann und die cdu hat sich
am ende für armin laschet entschieden
wenn sie armin laschet nicht
durchgesetzt hätte als kanzlerkandidaten
dann hätte man die cdu schon vor dem 26
september vergessen
ein punkt dagegen hat wenn armin laschet
die größe gehabt hätte in echter
selbsterkenntnis schon anfang dieses
jahres nicht mit der ständigen these
demografische umfragen sind faktisch
nichts er hätte die erkenntnis gehabt
ich bin als nordrhein-westfälischer
ministerpräsident nicht qua amt des
größten bundeslandes
selbstverständlicher weise geeignet
kanzler zu werden waren viele zweifelten
bis zur kanzlerin dann hätte er mit
allergrößter sagen können ich lasse den
besseren den freien weg und da hätte
diese ganze
für die csu interessant zusammenhang wir
über selbsterkenntnis zu reden ulrich
reitz ein kollege von der faz hat ja
geschrieben in den letzten tagen das was
die csu gerade veranstalteter
veranstaltet hat vor dem csu-parteitag
mit laschet das sei eine art selbstmord
aus angst vor dem tod ist es tatsächlich
so dass die csu jetzt eine niederlage
für laschet riskiert um möglicherweise
also soll dann als zukünftiger
kanzlerkandidat da besser dazustehen in
dem wettbewerb mit der cdu gehen sie
dieses risiko ein weil dieser schuss
kann ja auch nach hinten losgehen
nein kann sie können keine planungen
machen über die nächsten vier jahre das
ist völliger völliger bullshit also das
ist es das ist echt daneben diese diese
spekulation die gestreut worden ist auch
hier im politischen berlin
die ist echt daneben wie wir uns erlaubt
unsere verfassung auch den dass markus
söder immer noch bundeskanzler wirklich
will dass nur einmal gesagt haben das
kann man noch erklären wenn man will
aber das ist auch durchaus noch möglich
nach einer ziemlichen wahlniederlage
wenn sie armin laschet tatsächlich ein
pferd ich glaube man man macht sich
keinen kopf über die persönlichkeit von
armin laschet er ist ein star
er ist kein feigling armin laschet ist
immer derjenige der immer zuletzt noch
gestanden ist als alle anderen schon von
der bildfläche verschwunden waren keiner
hat also jedenfalls meines wissens hat
keiner der spitzenpolitiker die jetzt zu
gebote stehen in deutschland hat so
viele niederlagen auf seinem konto wie
armin laschet und ist immer wieder
aufgestanden
also die vorstellung dass der eine
kanzlerkandidatur oder vorher schon den
cdu-vorsitz das war ja genau dieselbe
diskussion und möbel den cdu-vorsitz
dollar verzichten zugunsten von
förderlich märz das hätte der nie getan
oder die kanzlerkandidatur abgeben
zugunsten von markus oder das hätte er
nie gezahlt armin laschet ist ein
knallharter pokerspieler und in der
nacht in dieser berühmten nacht auf
dialoge an spielt in der wolfgang
schäuble
und volker bouffier
dafür gesorgt haben dass söder ist nicht
wurde da gab es die entscheidende szene
als markus söder gefragt hat armin
laschet direkt ins gesicht
habe ich die unterstützung von dir für
den fall dass sich kanzlerkandidat bin
und laschet hat gesagt nein die hast du
nicht die härte die müssen sie erst mal
aufbringen laschet ist ganz konträr zu
seinem image in der öffentlichkeit und
zu seinen weichen gesichtszügen und zu
seinem rheinischen singsang ein
knallharter machtpolitiker der seine
interessen im zweifelsfall auch gegen
größte widerstände
durchsetzen das muss man einfach auf der
pfanne haben und auf der lotter haben
und einen bemerkungen noch also ich
finde dass gerade fans vor der
landtagswahl drei wochen vor der
landtagswahl in nordrhein westfalen hat
er sieben prozent zurück gelegen
gegenüber hannelore kraft 7 prozent und
er hat das aufgeholt und herr keller hat
ja eben gefragt was kann eigentlich die
cdu jetzt noch machen oder die union
damals hat er es geschafft indem er
wolfgang bosbach aus der tasche gezogen
hat und das thema innere sicherheit nach
vorne gezogen hat eines der kernthemen
der union und der spd sozusagen und der
regierung von hannelore kraft ihr
versagen in der kölner silvesternacht
hin geschrieben hat und er und das
versagen von ihrem innenminister
jäger die innere sicherheit war damals
2017 für armin laschet das gewinnerthema
von klaus
bei aller wertschätzung bereits ich in
meinem eindruck nach fallen sie hier
volle kanne auf das fleming der cdu
rhein die ja versucht armin laschet
darzustellen als einer der nicht
austeilen kann aber eben einstecken kann
also einer der der nicht angreift aber
steher qualitäten hat und so schon aber
selbst als er damals gegen hannelore
kraft gewonnen hat
laschet ist doch immer der typ der
gesiegt hat weil sich im zweifelsfall
die mehrheit gegen jemand anderen
entschieden hat wann hat sich denn
irgendwann mal jemand für armin laschet
entschieden die leute wollten damals
hannelore kraft abwählen das hat armin
laschet genutzt deswegen dieser
ministerpräsident geworden als er
parteivorsitzender wurde bei der cdu
haben sich die delegierten gegen märz
entschieden und als als kanzlerkandidat
wurde eben nur deshalb weil sich die
mehrheit gegen markus söder entschieden
hat weil sie dem augusta nicht getraut
haben und zu recht auch ja weil
er von luca sie sagten ja vorhin super
wäre der bessere kandidat gewesen oder
der der bessere kanzler gewesen da gibt
es schon auch ein unterschied also ich
glaube auch dass markus söder der
bessere kanzler kandidat gewesen wäre
aber ich glaube nicht dass markus söder
im vergleich zu armin laschet der
bessere kanzler gewesen wäre zieht man
ja jetzt wie er sich eben verhält haben
sie ja schön beschrieben lucke das heißt
dass wir nicht als team player nicht auf
dieser platte und das regelbuch glaube
ich wäre markus söder auch kein guter
kanzler darum geht es aber so leicht die
kelsterbacher wald kanzlerkandidat wäre
er gewesen ja vor klaus will das ist
interessant das ist eine große hypothese
die ist anzustellen ob der
charakterlichen länger über die keiner
von uns hinwegsehen kann die markus
söder ersichtlich hat aber für eine
partei information wie cdu csu muss es
ganz schlicht in der situation der frage
um den macht erwerb auch darum gehen wer
dieses wer diese formation ins ziel
bringt und insofern finde ich
tatsächlich auch die heroisierung von
den reiz rühren man muss sich verstellen
bereits am ende wird es so sein selbst
wir haben am anfang darüber gesprochen
selbst wenn armin laschet ein stück die
nase vorn hat dann werden sicherlich die
truppen aus nordrhein-westfalen wer es
auch immer sein wird zur erotischen
klängen an stimmen aber er wird über 10%
verloren haben er wird von einem absolut
sicheren über 30 prozent ergebnis auf
das historisch schlechteste ergebnis der
cdu csu in der geschichte herab gefallen
sein das ist eine eine niederlage ganz
egal ob er die 2% oder 2 promille am
schluss vor scholz liegt und das ist das
dilemma der cdu/csu und ich sage das
ganz unabhängig wirklich übrigens
wirklich von von von partei sympathien
es wird übrigens ein gewaltiges auch für
uns historisches neues phänomen seien
mit der letzten geschrumpften
volkspartei das war die letzte
gestandene volkspartei wir müssen uns
bewusst machen wo die spd eigentlich er
kam die spd kam von 8,4 prozent in
mecklenburg vorpommern
die spd stand deutlich unter 20 prozent
nur weil die grünen ist auch nicht
geschafft haben die linke mitte dass man
ihn ja eigentlich konzedierte sie werden
den wachwechsel
einleiten er ist die spd überhaupt auf
der seite wieder in nummer eins stellung
geraten jetzt ist sie wieder in der lage
das ist armin laschet zu danken dass sie
wieder über 20 prozent steht aber die
union wird auch eine deformierte
volkspartei sein und damit wird die die
er das erbe von armin laschet sein dass
er uns nach dem 26 09 so ist nicht noch
einmal zu einer ja schon wahnsinnig
geschrumpften eigentlich gar nicht mehr
großen koalition zu nennen spd cdu csu
konstellation kommt dann wird er uns zu
neuen dreier konstellation führen und
dann wie dann der heroismus bereits von
herr laschet dem stehe aussehen wird
diese dreier konstellation zu einer
tatkräftigen schlagkräftigen
konstellation zu bringen das möchte ich
erleben normalerweise das war noch vor
einem jahr absoluter sachstand wäre bei
einem starken cdu csu ergebnis und bei
auch staaten grünen klassischerweise
eine schwarz-grüne koalition am platz
gewesen das wäre für die stabilität
dieses landes wahrscheinlich nicht das
schlechteste gewesen und deswegen frau
klaus ich lasse mich da gar nicht darauf
ein herr söder hat uns schon manche
überraschung gelehrt momentan scheint
die zustimmung in bayern trotz der
charakterlichen schwierigkeiten
ausgesprochen erstaunlich an manche
leute verändern sich im amt durchaus
bemerkenswert dass der sender nun genau
die seehofer schon qualitäten der
schmutz er ist von ehrgeiz zerfressen
jetzt genau am beispiel armin laschet
durch exerziert das haben wir erlebt
aber trotzdem einen ihrer konstellation
nach den sechs und amber mit einer so
schwachen cdu csu ein erbe das sich
nicht zuletzt an mir ein bild von ihnen
deformierte volkspartei union und spd
meint sie ja von lucke was bedeutet das
eigentlich jetzt für die zeit nach der
bundestagswahl der ball kommt es
irgendwann vorbei die persönlichen
auseinandersetzungen auch das so sagen
hat einen ganz anderen blick auf die
politik corona ist ein thema klima
außenpolitik noch einiges andere
sozialsysteme reformieren die frage wie
es in der wirtschaft weitergeht steuern
erhöhen oder senken oder lassen wie geht
man mit der schuldenbremse und das sind
ja alles ganz wichtige themen die jetzt
auch eine lösung oder aber auf eine
lösung warten was bedeutet das wenn da
zwei angeschlagenen boxer oder
deformierte volksparteien dann die einen
vielleicht der opposition die anderen in
der regierung möglicherweise aber in
einer koalition zusammen das land
regieren wollen das bedeutet dass es am
ende zu einer ganz großen koalition
kommen wird die nächsten vier jahre
mindestens egal wie am ende die
konstellation aussieht und die ist auch
wenn man auf die sozialpolitik schaut da
guckt er im moment keiner hin aber wenn
man darauf wenn man weiß dass in den
nächsten vier jahren eine grundlegende
reform eine rentenversicherung fällig
ist und weiß auch dass
rentenversicherungs reformen in aller
regel in großen koalitionen also mit
beteiligung damals eben der
bundesregierung und des bundesrates
ausgemacht worden sind und auch
ausgemacht werden mussten damit sie
akzeptiert werden sowohl von den
rentnern als auch von den
beitragszahlern dann wird man eben diese
konstellation wenn es gut geht also man
es gibt ja zwei möglichkeiten entweder
diese dreier konstellationen die am ende
wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich regieren
wird zerstreitet sich ganz schnell und
dann haben wir eben nichts und haben
auch keine lösung die andere lösungen
die ich aber für wahrscheinlicher halte
ist dass man angesichts der grossen
themen klima rente ganz vorne
sich entscheiden wird eben
konstruktiv zu regieren und zumindest
der ein oder andere partner in dieser
regierung ist ja auch bekannt dafür dass
er konstruktiv oder sie konstruktiv ist
und wenn man das tut dann wird man eben
diese rentenreform die die letzte große
koalition eben weil sie aus zwei ich
würde nicht sagen deformierten
volksparteien besteht sondern aus
entleerten volksparteien die cdu hat
keinerlei
programminhalt mehr und die spd ist in
den letzten acht jahren so getauscht
worden auch durch ihre beteiligung an
der regierung dass sie eigentlich auch
keinen programmatischen kern mehr hat wo
man sagen könnte also heute würde man
sagen oder scholz transportiert das
stabilitäts gehen der spd aber dahinter
gibt es eben eine spd die nach links
will und die auch nach links rücken will
das heißt beide parteien sind eigentlich
leer und diese parteien können nur wenn
sie es wenn es ihnen gelingt eine
konstruktive regierungskoalition zu
machen die sachthemen löst und die
sachthemen sind sozialpolitik rente und
die sind klima wenn sie die wenn sie das
nicht schaffen dann sind sie weg wenn
sie das schaffen dann haben sie die
chance sich auch in der regierung wieder
sozusagen mit sinn zu füllen bereits es
gibt ja in diesem sofortprogramm das
armin laschet gestern vorgestellt hat
hat er ja noch einmal bekräftigt auf
keinen fall wird es steuererhöhungen
geben obwohl er angekündigt hat als
kanzler muss ja erstmal auch vor allem
wegen der korona krise ein kassensturz
gemacht werden gleichzeitig will er
relativ kurzfristig wieder die
schuldenbremse einführen wenn man das
jetzt so alles nebeneinander hält gingen
das ein bisschen wie die quadratur des
kreises
hat er da inhaltlich ein klares konzept
nein sicher nicht
ich erinnere daran dass bei dem
regierungsprogramm der union vorher
entwürfe basiert sind die ganz andere
steuersätze vorgesehen haben als die die
jetzt genannt bzw nicht genannt werden
es ist einfach so dass die parteien im
moment und das ist auch legitim also das
macht mich nicht nervös zu sehen einfach
dass jede partei jetzt ihre
wunschvorstellungen zu protokoll gibt
wie das hinterher in
koalitionsverhandlungen
aussieht ist eine ganz andere sache und
wird entscheidend davon abhängen
wer letztlich letztendlich in der rolle
eines königsmachers
sein wird wenn die fdp so stark werden
sollte wie das im moment sich abzeichnet
dann läuft das in eine andere richtung
wie die wie etwa in einer koalition in
der die grünen noch die königsmacher
wären oder sogar in einer rot-rot-grünen
koalition die ich keineswegs abschreiben
würde überhaupt nicht weil das stimmt
was frau weidenfeld eben gesagt hat dass
die spd als partei und der funktionärs
körper der spd deutlich nach links will
und die diskussion über eine
rot-rot-grüne koalition ist das vehikel
auch programmatisch für die spd nach
links zu kommen und insofern kann man
kann man das überhaupt nicht wegdrücken
die koalitionsfrage frau klaus spieler
jetzt auch eine rolle nach der wahl was
vermutet sie denn die csu hat ja schon
ausgeschlossen dass sie als
juniorpartner der spd in eine koalition
eintreten würde auf der anderen seite
gibt es ja verschiedene optionen die
durchaus wahrscheinlich sind die ampel
oder jamaika das hat ja unterrichts
gerade angedeutet und die fdp dann auch
mit dabei ist was glauben sie denn was
in der richtung passieren wird erleben
wir da noch überraschungen was die
positionierung der union angeht jetzt
wissen wir zwar nicht das wahlergebnis
aber hat man da vorstellungen bei cdu
und csu was nach einem nicht allzu
glänzenden wahlergebnis da passieren
könnte
also man hofft ja jetzt auf den letzten
metern die eigene wählerschaft
mobilisieren zu können in die richtung
welt uns sonst bekommt ihr die anderen
also wir erleben ja gerade so eine
pseudo rote socken kampagne als hätte
irgend wer angst vor dem einmarsch der
russen also heutzutage muss man ja
irgendwie mehr angst haben dass der
dorfbach überläuft als dass jede neue
kalte krieg ausbricht aber trotzdem die
hoffnung ist natürlich dass man jetzt
auf den letzten metern noch die eigenen
leute mobilisiert durch die angst vor
rot rot grün also angst vor grün hat die
csu eigentlich überhaupt nicht markus
söder hat schon vor einem halben jahr
die kampagne der csu darauf ausgerichtet
den grünen wählern die stimmen
abzuluchsen also er hat doch immer
gesagt er könnte sich am ehesten ein
schwarz grünes bündnis vorstellen also
ich bin mal gespannt ob die grünen
vielleicht jetzt auch auf den letzten
metern noch
zuwächse haben und ob wir vielleicht
doch schwarz grün noch erleben könnten
oder jamaika erleben könnten also darauf
hofft glaube ich jedenfalls also die csu
seite der cdu csu der union hofft auf so
ein jamaika bündnis auf zusammenschluss
mit den grünen und da wäre ja auch
markus söder der anschluss fähigeren
type anschluss fähiger als armin laschet
der ja in seinem bundesland nrw kohle
hat und damit eigentlich nicht so der
natürliche partner der grünen ist aber
markus söder tut sich da leichter wir
haben ja keine kohlekraftwerke in bayern
und ja das wäre eigentlich seine
wunschvorstellung jamaika ein aspekt
vielleicht was die fdp angeli backert ja
gerade das wählerpotenzial der unions
sozusagen von der anderen seite an
glauben sie dass die fdp gestärkt aus
dieser wahl heraus geht das wird sich
zeigen momentan versucht gerade die
union wiederum die stimmen der fdp
zurück zu gewinnen das ist doch das
interessante dass die union versucht
jetzt deutlich zu machen es ist
entscheidend wer kanzler wird und da ist
ja auch der richtige punkt der union
getroffen es geht in den letzten wochen
um eine entscheidende frage kann die
union den vorsprung vielleicht wirklich
völlig wettmachen kann sie vor laschet
einlaufen vor scholz einlaufen und kann
sie vielleicht sogar und das wird meines
erachtens bei der entscheidung zwischen
jamaika und und der ampel dann der
entscheidende punkt sein ich halte für
eine rot rot grüne koalition für völlig
ausgeschlossen wenn ich völlig anderer
ansicht als der reiz weder scholz noch
die grünen man muss nur heute das
interview von frau bär burg in der
süddeutschen lesen irgendeine classic
mittel benutzt hätten aber was bringen
die fdp hat mit immer so hingestellt
aber wer olaf scholz kennt und das
kennen viele fdp-leute olaf scholz wird
wissen dass ihm das druckmittel nicht
sonderlich nahe liegt denn das ist keine
sonderliche neigung muss sich bewusst
machen sowohl grüne wie auch spd waren
die hauptgegner der linkspartei wurden
als polizist und dergleichen gibt er
denunziert aber der entscheidende punkt
ist doch der gelingt es einer der beiden
parteien spd oder cdu so einen abstand
zwischen den anderen zu legen und sagen
wird 3 prozent das ein echter
regierungsauftrag an diese stärkere
partei erteilt das wäre besonders
eklatant wenn es die spd wenn die cdu
tatsächlich am ende 3 prozent hinter der
spd landet dann halte ich es fast für
ausgeschlossen dass man bei einem
solchen absturz doch überhaupt einen
regierungsanspruch für sich reklamiert
und dann werde ich 69 900 680
tatsächlich der fall war es aber
interessanterweise so war dass die cdu
nicht von 33 prozent auf 23 prozent
abstürzt und 1 markus söder dahinter ist
der im zweifel keine allzu große neigung
hat mit einem solchen ergebnis eine
wacklige koalition einzugehen sondern
sagt ich werde lieber gegen ein
schwaches bündnis in der führung von
olaf scholz eine ampel koalition in
berlin dann aus aus aus münchen front
machen das ist für die meisten gerichten
verwalten feld glauben sie dass der
union als kurze andere bitte gelingen
wird der mieter noch wähler zu
mobilisieren die vielleicht sie wirklich
wählen wollten dann jetzt nicht wählen
wollen vielleicht dann doch wieder
wählen was ist diese
orientierungsfähigkeit der union die
union mobilisiert jetzt sie muss
mobilisieren und die union hat immer
gezeigt und das ist dass die dass er
auch das erbe von angela merkel aus 16
jahren im zweifel geht es um die macht
und dann ist das wahlergebnis
zweitrangig angela merkel hat die
schlechtesten wahlergebnisse eingefahren
die man hatte die man haben konnte außer
2013 sie hat immer regiert und sie hat
regieren wollen weil sie die macht
wollte und das ist das was die cdu heute
ausmacht und das muss sie übergehen 26
67 sekunden zu verteilen und da alle
vier gäste was wird aus armin laschet
oder nicht bundeskanzler wird
derzeit in ein ruhigeres und das war der
grund warum bereits völlig recht hat er
mag viel riskiert haben am ende hatte
alles verloren nach düsseldorf kann er
nicht zurück bereits
was wird aus ja und wer das scheint mir
jetzt schon festzustehen
wenn er die wahl so verliert das eine
kanzlerschaft mit welchem ergebnis auch
immer nicht mehr möglich ist dann ist er
nicht nur weg aus der berliner politik
damals ein außerordentlich kurzer
ausflug sondern ist er auch nicht mehr
haltbar als ministerpräsident in
düsseldorf und als pförtner auszusetzen
wir haben das letzte wort
einsatz bitte
ja er macht auch eine gute figur als
als gartenzwerg gartenzwerg für chur als
wm maskottchen und sicherlich als bester
freund und dass ich vor jeder die
angriffsspitzen amt antritt verdient
respekt und
das für dich geht für meinen augen
geprägt ist gerade aus münchen es lebe
also gut
wir werden an dieser stelle die sendung
jetzt zu ende bringen ich bedanke mich
bei uns in der weiten feld bei alltours
von lucke bei einer klaus und bei ulrich
reitz die zuschauer morgen das thema
sozusagen auf die andere partei die
möglicherweise den kampf einstellen
können fokussiert mit dem titel im
umfragehoch woher kommt der aufwand für
die spd jetzt lege ich ihnen julia grimm
ans herz und die sendung für nix der tag
darin unter anderem die klimadebatte
heute aus dem europäischen parlament
bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]